on item 12 the cell allocations uh one
of the items concerns um fny Compton
Parish which uh is in the TW member Ward
uh I had no um involvement whatsoever in
the bid um so I just note that interest
and I would intend to remain and take
part in the
discussion thank you councelor rock
councelor
Gest um item 12 again I um did help fny
Compton Parish Council write their bid
so I propos to leave the
room
leader can I just check with Council
call you will be leaving the meeting for
that particular item thank
you right the next item uh is the
minutes and this is to confirm and sign
the minutes of the meeting held on the
6th of November
2023 has anybody got any comments and if
so um please let me know if not we will
confirm and sign the minutes as
agreed
anybody no we confirm oh happy to
confirm it okay thank
you uh next item is the um the My under
comes under my portfolio and that's the
council plan and this is to consider the
proposed council plan and the vision for
2023 to 27 uh following the results of
the consultation and these are on pages
92122 so it's quite a big item uh and it
agrees the vision
and um it will be the plan that will set
the overall direction for this Authority
and be a strategic guiding document to
meet the Ambitions of the council over
the next four
years it has had input from all key St
stakeholders uh I found in particular
the responses uh from people that had
responded to the consultation and also
the um statistics that came
looking at some of the um the issues
that confi that um address that we need
to address in our area the um the the um
the documentation on the age of people U
the profile various items across the uh
District uh I foundre really
interesting the we've got it helps us
because it gives us a thorough
understanding of the local area
priorities not only our priorities but
the priorities of the people that have
responded especially during a time of
financial
restraint um this Council continues to
be in strong financial position but with
ever more scarce resources it's
important to maintain continued
attention to where those resources are
allocated so I it's um for debate if
anybody has it there are six specific
priorities local economy affordable well
build and maintained homes health and
well-being climate change delivery of
service and residents and communities
have we got anybody that wants to make
any comment at this
stage councilor W huggings I'll just
reiterate the fact that we're in a
strong financial position because the
conservatives who are uh previously in
charge of this Council were unafraid of
making the difficult decisions with
regard to the one two3 uh Bin charges
and with regard to car parking charges
just to name one or two we were unafraid
of making the big decisions that make
the right decision to make sure that
this Council was on a sound financial
footing unlike other councils uh in the
near vicinity thank
you thank you very much um anybody else
that wants to make any other
comments coun CO's uh thank you leader
no I just wanted to say that I think
this has been an extremely useful piece
of work I think we're very happy with
the results and certainly that uh the
priorities are very clear for this
Administration and what we want to to do
for our residents in in in the district
I I was very heartened by some of the
consultation responses that came back um
that uh showed that we were on the right
tracks as far as that local people were
concerned and when it does come to
finance it we really ought to also make
the point about um um that um this local
Authority as with all local authorities
so far have only been given a one-year
settlement um and the lack of certainty
about the finances that are be coming
from government um is hindering
financial planning for all authorities
but um and hindering the the the way
that we plan things here at the district
council I hope that message gets through
to government at some point but finally
um councilor Rock do you want to come in
and then I've got one final Point yes
thank you uh chair um
I I I studied with great interest uh the
feedback and I thank the officers for
for carrying that work out uh and
although there there is a sort of
ranking in here the interesting thing to
me I'm a I'm a great fan of Pito
principles the old 8020 Rule and it's
quite heartening to note that the
responses of the aims we've got in all
cases uh we we've got 80% agreement
and the way the way it's set out here
what is also interesting there's a few
the comments are quite
informative
um of a an inherent problem that we've
got with the geography of the district
um the two there's a two to one ratio of
comments that refer to the town rather
than the district because of our
problem of communicating with the wider
The Wider District uh and uh I talked to
Simon perfield our our
uh Communications officer carried out
this survey and uh we don't know quite
what to do about that but it just
illustrates how hard it is to
communicate with those rural areas even
though we've taken a great deal of
trouble to communicate through the
parishes um but um generally speaking
very positive that um we've hit on those
aims that that's a task to be dealt with
and I think this um desire we've got to
make better use of the parishes uh that
we've stated is is something we need to
pursue thank you
chair um I I think um councelor um do
you want to come in councelor Curtis
thank you yes Le just a small point I
think we when the the results are very
good from this survey and just picking
up Council Rock's comment about some um
perhaps more rural areas that are harder
to reach I think we also need to when
we're looking at these replies responses
is to look at the age waiting as well
because there obviously is an age
waiting um the vast majority are
unfortunately not under 25 um it's it's
uh 45 to 59 60 to
74 um so I think that's something that
perhaps we can consider in future hard
to reach groups are difficult to reach
by their very nature and perhaps for
future consultation exercises we could
consider further how we can reach
younger people as well thank you even
younger than those in this
room than thank you um I would urge um
all counselors but also particularly
cabinet members to keep the um some of
the the statistics by them because it
will it will kind of inform us as we go
forward one thing that I found um
particularly difficult is that uh when
it say stated on page 103 about the risk
of poverty that there is a Confluence of
factors Within in our district which
means that a number of our residents are
now at risk of being pushed into poverty
partly due to fuel poverty but also du
due to income pressures I think we need
to understand uh and bear that in mind
and those these statistics are extremely
useful in being able to identify for
example those households that are more
at risk um and those dist those wards
that are more at risk from certain um
issues and certain problems than others
uh and the feeling and the response back
about what people feel are their highest
priorities finally I would like to just
say thank you thank you to the team that
actually produced this council plan
thank you that's uh not only the ones
that came in to help us but also the
team within the district council who've
helped put some of the statistic
together they've worked extremely hard
on putting this council plan together I
think it's a an excellent council plan
and would like to recommend it so we've
got the um recommendation is to agree
the vision for Stratford on Haven
District Council and the council plan
for 2023 to 27 as shown in appendix one
and agree the public facing document
that is in appendix 2 and uh if subject
to everybody agreeing to that are you
happy for me move in
second I I seek somebody to to move it
counselor calls is moving it and
councelor Groot is seconding it are you
happy with that moving forward okay okay
agreed thank
you the next item is um an item that
comes under councelor culture's
portfolio and that is the South warshire
Economic Development strategy and action
plan and this is to consider the uh
plan for 2024 2025 Council
coucher thank you very much chair um I
think in many respects this report is a
Vindication I think of a decision which
um the council took some while ago about
putting more investment into U Economic
Development and I think that was a
liberal Democrat proposal chair in in a
previous
administration um uh I would recommend
this report to you and I would thank
Mark won and his team I think for
preparing a very professional um and a
very thorough and a very authoritative
document uh coming forward um the
document I think demonstrates that we
have an enor enormous potential
economically here in uh South warshire
um and it's part of the sub region in
including wari as well we've I think had
quite a lot of input into making sure
that the strategy does embrace all key
sectors and particularly tourism and
Hospitality which wasn't one of War's um
highest priorities but clearly is a very
very important sector uh for us here in
Stratford I think the way in which the
uh report is set out um in dealing with
people and productivity as well as place
is really really important people in our
district are our most important and
valuable resource um and and we need to
make sure that we are doing everything
that we can uh to to encourage um them
to uh maximize their potential um and
obviously productivity is extremely
important because that's how we increase
the wealth of of of our of our district
um I'm also really pleased to see um in
the report how we're going to uh do what
we can uh to support businesses um and
business uh creation and Business
Development within the district we have
very important businesses here um who
are creating a lot of jobs creating a
lot of wealth and we need to make sure
that they re remain as prosperous as
they possibly can be um for for for the
future so I would endorse this this
document and recommend that you approve
uh this is our Economic Development
strategy and our action plan going
forward uh with implementation to be
started on the 1st of April
2024 do I have any any comments uh
councilor W
hoggins uh yes councilor couch a nice
try but I'm afraid that you cannot take
the uh take the glory for this document
here or all the proposals because
everybody knows that the economic
development and economic sound judgment
has always been at the heart of
conservative objectives and uh the work
that was done with these major employers
over the last several decades is all
down to the conservatives and nothing to
do with the lib Dems and their spurious
proposals that they used to put to
council thank you very much indeed and
when you put things forward I'd like to
know the dates and times of when your
these uh proposals came to full Council
thank you very much
indeed um Ju Just as a a point of of of
um knowledge um it was in the liberal
Democrat amendment in four amendments in
four budgets that there should be an
economic development strategy officer um
to be able to bring forward High aims
and objectives and be able to um address
um grants and U make sure that local
businesses and particularly small
businesses could benefit better from uh
finances both at a national level and a
regional level and that was in in and
the first one was written by myself in
2011 the amendment I've got all the
details of that Amendment thank you very
much indeed uh I think the the actual
economic strategy uh is absolutely
excellent uh I really do thank the
officers for for putting all the hard
work into that as well as the the
portfolio holder it has taken a lot of
work um please could you send the um our
thanks back to uh the team who have done
an exceptional amount of work in a very
short time to be able to pull this
together I really am very very happy
with the with the
strategy we have recommendations to the
council um that the economic development
strategy councelor
passingham thank you um yeah I I agree
and on on the whole it's very good
strategy but there are two things that
do concern me in terms of climate change
and carbon emissions in that obviously
this council is very concerned about
reducing carbon emissions but the
majority of carbon emissions or the
biggest factoring carbon emissions in
this district is transport and there's
two items in there one of which is the
support for making the a46 into an
expressway in other words making it du
Carriage Way has there been any
calculations of how much more traffic
that will um induce and the carbon
emissions produced by that traffic and
the other one is support for the
wellsborne airport because the um
Airfield because the most polluting form
of Transport in the whole country is
private
airplanes and why the council should be
deliberately supporting that that
airport which is really for the play
things for pretty rich people when
there's so much fuel poverty and other
things that are happening in this
District I in the district I don't
really uh
understand um councelor C do you want to
respond to that um and U just to to let
you know that I use the a46 a lot uh
there have actually been a lot of
accidents including one person that was
killed um recently on that um that that
um that road um so
that I am concerned about and I think we
this is a case probably where we need to
work in partnership with the County
Council what we we um what we do need to
do is make sure that um safety is is
taken into consideration on that road um
Council of cure um obviously
infrastructure is one of our key issues
here we've seen considerable growth
taking place across the districts over a
long period of time and our
infrastructure has not kept pace with
that the the a46 is currently um
overloaded um and a major problem um and
a constraint uh to to further growth
within the district clearly obviously um
this document does take into account
climate change and carbon um reduction
and and uh and that is a key
consideration when proposals are coming
forward in terms of making sure they
minimize that that impact in relation to
wellsborne Airfield um which is in
within my ward um clearly it's not just
purely uh a Leisure uh facility key
companies including uh two key companies
in wellsborne use that on a regular
basis uh to bring in uh Key Personnel
from Ireland and from Europe it does
have an economic um input in many
respects one of the key sectors that
we'll be promoting is uh how we are
dealing with technology in air uh road
and road Rail and the Airfield has a has
an input into into that so it's a very
very important component of of our our
local economy and that's one of the
reasons why this Council in the previous
administration and in this
Administration is giving a high priority
to ensuring that that airport that
Airfield is
protected councelor
Crump again just some you know with with
all other hats on on on the workshire
road safety partnership and we do
recognize that the traffic uh on the i46
and in particular when there's
congestion obviously where's congestion
there potentially more pollution so
that's that's one of the issues that we
take into account but I think important
that it is looked at in in terms
particularly regarding road safety and I
believe um latest accident involved a
pedestrian quite late at night um so
again we just need to make sure you know
any expansion is is done in the right
way because if it's not done properly
people then be using rat runs invariably
do if there's congestion and then
potentially we're having vehicles going
down roads that w't specifically
designed to take those Vehicles so I
think we need to look at it in a hole
and and broadly I support the the
investment in in the and that road and
I'm as you say cancer junor you use that
regularly so you you know about do as
well so um just some I did points and
hope you find them
half yeah yes this that's my roote home
and you know at nighttime the number of
lers that use that road um I think you
know this is this is something that does
need where we need to work in in
partnership with the County
Council you know the um I I know of more
than one person that was killed but more
in recent times there's certainly one
person that killed uh one thing that is
in the in the um the uh the economic
strategy is that a recognition that a
carbon neutral economy is a significant
uh opportunity for this area and it's
one that it we that wants to be worked
on the rapid decarbonization of emission
sources um Falls outside the jurisic
jurisdiction of local authorities but um
there is a lot of companies within this
area who could be part of the solution
and that is recognizing um in that uh in
this Economic Development strategy that
we want to be able to um encourage and
support those those um companies not
only to to support and reduce their own
carbon footprint and look at circular
economy Etc all of which is in this
Economic Development strategy but also
to encourage those companies that will
be part of the of the uh solution for
the future because we do need to get to
Net Zero and uh we need to encourage
those companies that will help us to do
so including those that will be able to
give us the Transport Solutions of the
future um we we're we're ramping up on
electric vehicles but eventually there
will be other solutions for lorries and
other transport and we need to encourage
and support uh there is mentioned within
the economic development strategy about
um the rail Innovation uh as well as um
the major Motor companies um and as well
as U companies like and organizations
like War University that are trying to
work on innov innovative solutions and
we do need to find those Solutions in
order to be able to go towards net zero
for the future
so um with that councelor passingham do
you want to come
back all those things are very
important uh but um coming back to the
a46 I think safety is a different matter
to make it into an
expressway uh there are lots of safety
measures that could be taken uh to make
it a lot safer um but it's well known
proved by all sorts of studies that
improving roads making them into dual
carriageway just induces more traffic
and most of that traffic will be
diverted off the main
motorways um and it'll just be coming
straight past Stratford um so it won't
be um improving the um uh reduction in
carbon emissions um a lot of that the
the lores should should be on freight on
rail uh and the improvements in the rail
system is obviously going to help to
that but um so I don't see um any
advantage in making into jaw c r on the
other on the other point about about at
wellsborne airport I mean why should um
um Executives of large companies be
flying into PR in private jets into a
local airport when there are there's
Birmingham air airport there's lots of
other ways to to move around the country
and in fact it be far better not not to
use uh um uh flight at all but to use
zoom or teams nowadays and there's a lot
less traffic evidently since covid
people aren't aren't on the road so much
now so we should be thinking about how
we can reduce road traffic clear clearly
uh Council passingham you do not use the
a46 on a regular basis um but I I
understand the history of wellsborne
field is to be able to actually reduce
um is is uh the number of um movements
or Lorry movements in know that using
you know could be build where having
warehousing on on the site there is
there are other things that need to be
considered councelor W W
huggings uh thank you just to reiterate
i' I've said it before a meeting that
the maintaining the Airfield at
wellsborne is not only to do with how
the current operations are operating
there it is about protecting an Airfield
which with the future technologies that
are coming online that Airfield will be
critical to to that um uh the Drone
corridors that are being set up for
deliveries that kind of thing that is
everybody knows that that is how the um
transplant service is going to be
operated very soon I that to have the
narrow Vision that just to stop that any
practice there because people can have a
use a different airport really means
that fundamentally have to look at the
other economic opportunities for this
District this District of having an
Airfield in our midst and that's why as
conservatives we've been very strong
about wanting to protect the air
Airfield at Wells born is precisely
because it should be tying into um the
documents before us today with regard to
the uh economic development in the South
so I think um you know we we've heard
the rhetoric about um a miles Etc but we
we do really have to preserve it for the
other uses that that is going to be uh
for and that in the longterm that will
reduce the carbon footprint of of other
Industries people have choices and they
make them and we don't know what the
offsetting of people that are using
those Transport
Systems are doing thank you very much
indeed thank you um on we have a number
of recommendations to the council um and
one is that the economic development
strategy and action plan will be adopted
with implementation starting from the
1st of April 2024 subject to the
agreement and adoption by full councils
of both Stratford and War district
councils and then subject to that the
authority be delegated to the head of
development in consultation with the
planning and economic development
portfolio holder to make any minor
changes prior to its publication and
over to oversee the annual review of
this action plan and to monitor its
implementation according to the district
council's corporate plan economic
priorities do I have anybody that will
move that um that uh Rec those
recommendations councelor coucher are
happy to remove it to to move it uh and
somebody to to second that um councelor
Kurtis thank you very much indeed are
you all agreed thank you moving on to
the next item which is the growing
opportunities plan 2023 to 25 uh which
is on page 195 to 230 to consider the
growing opportunities plan to replace
the existing social inclusion strategy
and again um this this this one comes
under counselor calls but again there
are some interesting statistics uh which
are very very useful indeed um you know
in in going forward thank you councelor
count counselor Co my apologies thank
you
chair okay
um SDC has had a social inclusion
statement and has has worked with the
social inclusion partnership since
2014 um and there was a second iteration
produced in 19 to
24 however this has been somewhat
superseded by the introduction of the
government's leveling up agenda um
County Council have produced a
countywide plan in response to this and
the five districts within the county are
producing their own District plans um
although the county are obviously
responsible for some of the delal s
within the district areas as well um the
plan here will replace the former Social
inclusion
statement um and without wishing to toot
our trumpet we seem to be ahead of the
game somewhat on this and uh this
document is part of 12 months work with
Partners who formed the social inclusion
partnership and obviously councelor
junor you and I have both been to
meetings where some of this work has
carried out and it's been very
encouraging and positive to to see the
work that's been done um all the members
um are all part of this pack
um we do recognize that we will have to
bring in more diverse range of members
in order to identify and deliver some of
the objectives within our
plan um the partners are both statutary
and voluntary and the aim of this plan
the objectives that we have are to
improve residents lives make life more
equal with Le of a dist dis sorry
difference between richer and poorer
areas this plan is strategic and I think
it
will complement and deliver the
objectives of our new council plan um
the action plan in terms of what
actually we are going to deliver the
ground which when we come down to it is
the whole point of these these
operations will be brought to Cabinet in
January
um and it will pick up any outstanding
and ongoing actions from the social
inclusion statement to make sure we
haven't overlooked anything in the
transition between the old plan and the
new
um the housing communities team lead and
work with Partners enabling the delivery
of key objectives rather than the
council delivering the services directly
and I think this is one of the strengths
of the council is that we can act as an
enabler coordinating bringing together
different interested parties and I
certainly saw that in action in these
meetings where we had members of
different groups coming sitting at
tables and working through problems and
I think this is certainly a key strength
that we can bring to this process as a
council um this plan has to be approved
by the council and therefore today I am
seeking uh a
recommendation that um you approve this
plan thank you
so um you are moving the the
recommendation um do I see um a second
and then I'll anybody else want
counselor G uh any councelor do you want
to come in at this point yes the
conservative group are heartened indeed
as a result of the conservative
governments leving leveling up Bill that
the lib Dems have managed to Galvanize
themselves into updating this document
thank you and
policy I I I think that um a little bit
um you know does doesn't exactly help
with all the officers that took part in
this and put such a lot of hard work in
that I think we need to be a little more
supportive of the work that they've done
uh they have done a lot it is a
partnership approach we continue to
support the aims of that partnership
approach uh and do so with enthusiasm uh
thank you very much indeed now we've had
us do councelor rock do you want to come
in it it's just a comment chair if I may
I may make it uh which which is a
general point which I've banged
uh banged on the bat since my time as a
counselor on page 211 we've got a map of
super output areas and
um I'm I'm sure when we're looking at
actions to take we're all aware of the
super output areas can disguise very
small pockets of deprivation uh and I
know about those in particular in rural
areas um
and it tends to wipe across very
large areas that um uh I'm not saying
one size fits all but it it can mask
certain things within that and I'm sure
when officers are considering actions to
take of that we just we just need to
bear that in mind this is very much an
indicator rather than absolute thank you
chair um councelor Crump councelor Rock
I obviously been been reading the same
paper or the same book because I was
going to say something very similar to
that I I think I think we you know these
these super output areas are are good
indicators um but they sure form the
basis of some of the resource
allocations and what partnership working
we do need to make sure we are engaging
with our towns and parishes and also
with local members to identify pockets
and areas of deprivation as well so I
think that's really important so and
again talking about Kel rocks Point area
where we were talking about really
mentioned uh parts of the east of the
district the rural District regarding
um responses to consultation and
communication with those areas as well I
think that Highlights Highlights the
issue as well so if we're doing that in
the round we can communicate we can
listen we can also identify previously
hidden or unseen areas of deprivation as
well so I think we've got a duty as that
as a council to to cover all parts of
the district not just certain parts so I
think that's that's quite a fair point
as well so basically agreeing with
Council The Rock and sort of like adding
on to it as well so you better make a
note of that Mrs Banks so in a minute so
thank you for that thank you very much
indeed um councilor hogins did you want
to come in again yes I did because I
think you got the wrong impression of
what I was saying because um my comments
I made we are well aware of how much
work officers are now having to do with
regards to uh these these policies thank
you and we are indeed as ever very
grateful for the work the officers do in
this Council and we're very very aware
of uh the need for them to have work
life balance as well thank you thank you
very much indeed there were there were
18 partners that put input to the uh
thing we've had this strategy uh which I
I recommend we've had some we've had a
mover and we've had a seconder are you
all agreed to adopting uh subject to
that going to does that have to go to
council or yes it goes to council okay
thank you very much
indeed moving on to the um matters for
decision by the cabinet um the quarter 2
performance monitoring report which is
on page 23 231 to
252 uh and um this comes under my
portfolio and it's a report to the
cabinet uh about the um position in
relation to the qu2 performance
monitoring report and any issues
identify for further cons consideration
to be addressed uh any item anybody that
wants to pick up on that at all
otherwise I uh there is a recommendation
I move that recommendation anybody
councilor coucher
secondly all agreed thank you very much
indeed next item is um the statford on
aen Gateway collabor collaboration
agreement page 253 to 264 and this is to
consider the uh the collaboration
agreement with the West Midlands
combined Authority in relation to the
acquisition of the Gateway site uh and
uh this comes under um counselor Rock
and counselor coucher between them so
um and I think I have an input small
input as
well so um anybody that wants to address
anything um what I would like to do is
to just make a slight Amendment to the
recommendation there is the first the
recommendation as it stands at the
moment is that Authority be delegated to
the chief executive in consultation with
the leader monitoring officer and
section 15 officer to agree a
collaboration agreement with the West
Midlands combined Authority in line with
the terms identified in paragraph
1.8.5 I'd like to just add a second one
uh which is uh on the um the the
recommendation of council Curtis as
portfolio holder for resources that we
have that the total assumed cost of 1
point
one05 million be funded from 1 million
and 55 1, 55 of the council's business
rates reserve and 50,000 from the
inflation earmark Reserve just to make
sure that we're quite clear about where
the funding is going to be coming from
should the um the uh collaboration
agreement go through and be
agreed is anybody else want to councelor
coucher chair I welcome this report um
this has been a site that has challenged
this Authority for a very long period of
time um and long last we've now got I
think a practical way forward and I very
much welcome um the proposals here
involving um the West Mills combined
Authority um this is a um site which is
not a great credit to Stratford district
and Stratford town in particular and I'd
be really really Keen to see um action
taking place um hopefully within the ter
within the time scale of this
Administration thank you and um just one
small correction under 5.2.2 table one I
believe the heading is incorrect but all
the detail in below is is correct I can
comment on that sorry for the area in
the report the table should be the
estimated cost of the Gateway
archaeological survey and holding cost
so apologies for that thank
you with those slight changes to the
recommendation and the and the change to
the the um heading of table one um I I'm
happy to move the recommendation do we
have a second councelor coucher has
seconded it and do we all agree to the
collaboration agreement um moving
forward okay agreed thank
you the next item is the future use of
council land for higher events and
attractions Pages 265 to 290 to consider
the introduction of an events policy and
this comes under councelor
grot thank you leader yes as it says on
the uh tin this is um concerning land
that the um Council the district council
controls um and the events a policy for
the events that are running um on it
throughout the year um quick fairly
quickly after we um I took this
portfolio we had an issue where we have
various um land in the district which
comes under the asset management of the
deputy chief executive and Council Rock
um and also the tourism side which comes
under councelor Cure and on development
um and we are finding that people could
make applications to hire out the um the
um uh recreational ground or bankrupt
Gardens Etc um without a one wi view
been taken of the impact on the tourism
and the uh visitors that were already
coming into the land and our existing
stakeholders as well such as the
contracts that come under my portfolio
as in the markets contracts and other um
um and other responsibilities that come
under this portfolio portfolio so um my
officers and myself have uh in
consultation with Nigel Rock have
actually come together with a policy
which outlines certain areas are
concerned so this is the um impact on
the higher um plan of Tourism and other
events already on and and also events
that we have on a regular basis down to
more operational issues such as the
closure of Roads um the environmental
and health and safety issues of the
events being under taken um and how it
also um leads into a broader uh um plan
of events going forward so this is more
like a holistic um plan to make sure
that these things happen in coordination
and there is a responsibility within my
portfolio now to make sure that these
things um the ward members affected are
in consulted in time and that we look at
our existing contractual obligations um
before things are um are agreed so this
is where this will be coming from um
also to make sure that we do not um you
know interfere with any of the other
existing stakeholders within the C
within the town and the district so I'd
like to recommend thank the um officers
for their hard work in producing this um
policy so um timely manner uh thank um
Council Rock for his input and to also
recommend that this event of policy be
move um to be moved um it could be
implemented quite quickly but what we do
recommend is that it doesn't actually um
come into Force until the 1 of April um
this gives um people who have um ongoing
and repeated events time to realize that
they have got to um now have this policy
um and make sure that they are you know
they um apply for the various licenses
and that in coordination with our
department in a timely way so thank
you so You' you've moved a
recommendation uh do we have anybody
that second it will second councelor
CO's any comments that were to be made
on this are we all in agreement no
councelor
cure can I just say uh I mean I think it
was one of the things I think we were
most surprised about when we took on the
administration there frankly wasn't a
policy statement in relation to this and
I think it's it's really been very good
that we've actually come forward with
this it's also very important because um
clearly there are financial implications
from this in terms of the income for the
for the for the district where we've not
been maximizing our potential there um
and and clearly it's really important
that we got this this state this
statement put in place because it was a
huge weakness from from what we
inherited the recommendation is that
this um goes from the cabinet to the
council for a final approval so um
subject to that are you all happy with
that and accept the the recommendations
thank
you the next item is the older people's
Engagement review page 291 to 304 um
which is to consider the approach to
engagement with and
consultation no yeah it's a consultation
of older people I was um rereading a
second uh recommendation so this comes
under councelor
CO's thank you chair uh we have two
recommendations uh linked to this one
following from the other um and this
comes from
um our fulfilling a requirement to
review our approach to engagement with
and consultation of older people um our
ability to consult with this group is
hugely important to us given the value
that it can bring to a fairly I'm afraid
fairly elderly District profile um the
report details
um the history of the uh housing and
communities team working with the groups
called scans which are the senior
citizens Action Network groups and how
interesting keeping these groups alive
with regular attendance has waned
somewhat over the years with two now
remaining those being statford and ships
um a lot of Officer effort has been put
into investing in resurrecting the
others but it is felt that really uh
having having put in this work there is
not much more that can be done going
down that road the team are Keen to cons
continue to support the groups that are
operational at the moment and he felt a
new model needs to be considered this
report suggests that this might include
members of the local voluntary sector
and not just of the older people
themselves
um bearing that in mind we feel the best
place for this work is to sit within the
growing opportunities action plan which
will be presented to the cabinet in
January
24 so bearing that in mind um my
recommendations the recommendations that
are here are that these this approach
the officers to continue to support the
two existing scans groups whilst
maintaining their support for a wider
health and well-being agenda be approved
um and this is a combination of the op
options um below and that the second
recommendation is that the forthcoming
growing opportunities action plan
developed with the social inclusion
partnership includes an action to work
with the remaining scan groups to
consider option three below to
investigate the interest in setting up a
Stratford District Forum to enhance the
contribution that older people can make
to run the development of services to
make to the development of services
within our
district thank you has anybody got any
comments that they want to make at this
point councelor Co are you moving th
those
recommendations do we have a second for
Council Groot is seconding yet are you
all agreed thank
you the next item is the ubz community
Transport Service bridging funding uh
quest for the quarter
20242 quarter 2 2024 25 and this comes
again under councelor KS would you like
to introduce the item thank you
chair since the last UBS report to the
cabinet meeting on October um we agreed
we would work with County to procure a
main bus service and potentially
procuring additional costed options for
further consideration forur funding by
this Council um unfortunately we've now
been advised by County they can't meet
the these procurement timetables in
order to deliver new contract with
effect from the 1st of April 2024 which
is what we had been planning towards um
the purpose of this report is to
highlight this position and to request a
an approval of a six-month budget from
April to September 24 of £60,000 to
enable migration to the new
service um as we've discussed in
previous meetings once these costed
options are known we will bring these
back to Cabinet to able a decision on
the future service model and therefore I
would seek approval of the
recommendation
here thank you are you prep prepared to
move that one uh yes I would move it
please and do we have a second for for
that um councelor Curtis and does
anybody have any comments if not I will
move that recommendation that we uh seek
the this extra budget to be able to make
sure that we can can deliver and uh
ensure that this service um survives
thank you next item is the seal spend
allocations pages one 317 to 360 and
this is to consider the proposed
allocation of available seal receipts
held by Stratford on aan District
Council as at 31st of March
2023 uh and this comes under counselor
culture as portfolio holder would you
like to introduce it uh thank you leader
um firstly I would want to make an an
apology obviously to the cabinet um that
the um this matter was reported the
previous cabinet but it had some um some
discrepancies within the report and I
know that was picked up at o that
overview and scrutiny picked that up
very very very strongly um so we have uh
now uh
recalibrated um the criteria uh in
relation to allocations we've done it
entirely in accordance with the um
criteria are set out um by the previous
administration um uh which I said at a
previous meeting that we would uh we
would uh adhere to um during this first
first year so uh I'll come on to the
recommendations in a moment what I do
want to say is clearly this is a matter
for review and I know that um uh head of
service um has that uh in his uh in his
work workload going forward and because
clearly there is is um some some very
major issues here that we have um
greatly a a great deal of additional
requirements for infrastructure spending
than we've got the money available for
we're not necessarily taking into
account some of the match funding that's
come forward in relation to some schemes
and actually the linkage between um
where we are actually investing on
infrastructure and where the
developments come from is is also quite
weak so we will be doing I think a
review process in relation to that
coming on now to the
recommendations um we're putting forward
recommendations that um we will um take
back uh the money in relation to wooden
Warren um primary school because that's
been funded
elsewhere and the allocations that we
are uh proposing uh to put forward are
the two uh key schemes which have the
highest score which is the statford
youth Collective the ministry center
statford youth club and Birmingham Road
and the learning and Community Hub um in
Henley
Street uh we're also
recommending uh that the project for
South warshire Community Diagnostic
Center at statford hospital where we're
contributing a million pound to an 8
million pound scheme uh also should go
forward we then had some difficulty I
think because we had a number of schemes
that then had a very similar score um uh
and we have proposed that actually
because in the previous report we had
recommended that the fenic Compton
Sports and play facility and lington
Village Hall would be funded we've
agreed to put those forward again this
time because we have the money to cover
them unfortunately um we can't do uh
another three schemes U which come
within that same same criteria um but
that is the recommendation that we're
putting forward to you today so it's
it's really I think under the table that
we have on page um 325 it's option
D thank you very much and I I certainly
welcome the the fact that you the the
the scoring system and the priority
system is going to be relooked at I
think it does need uh it does need doing
uh and um and happy that um we we've
been able to do um those two that were
were disappointed last time as well as
the h priorities essential that we make
sure that the the hospital is is funded
as well so um any comments councelor
Crump yeah I hope you don't want come in
coming in there rather than as part of
the general report because it's I think
it's really pertinent now um yeah we
discussed this in quite a bit of detail
and it's good to to see that um Mr
careford and Council C have taken on
board the the comments uh quite strong
comments on on the process and
um uh and some of the scoring um
anomalies shall we say I think we'll use
that word I can think of other words but
that sounds a sounds a good one don't
know what it means but it sounds good um
so that that has been taken into account
uh and we have seen um some revisions to
the scoring and and and the
projects um I think members still have
got concerns about
deliverability that's got to be a key
consideration and and facts and also
that some of the smaller less expensive
projects you I think there was one for
about 3,000 in the list one for about
177,000 could potentially be used by uh
using the so money that would otherwise
be carried
over um there were some concerns about
the so Mone is relating to the
ICB um it's part of the report so we
again we need to make sure we've got
some clarity around the spending and in
use of that money um as we all know that
is quite a Hot Topic at the moment and
the ICB actually did come to um the
previous uh ons to discuss that um we
endorsed the the recommendations for the
two projects but um because of the
uncertainty um we thought it's probably
we would limit to
that account
multitasking
um again we're certainly um
we're eager to assist council counil
with the revision the process um and
again there was we wanted some
reassurance that in the process that um
that money was being spent as intended
um that's going to be a real key
consideration in any progress and
obviously with any delay in the process
um we've got inflation and obviously the
allocation of a million pounds today is
um far worth far more than it been um
spent in five years time where the
inflation of we're not getting the same
bang for our Bookers they say I think
that's was the right phrase isn't it
cancer
Curtis something like that yeah just
making sure you're still awake so that
was good um so I think we've got to make
sure the money is spent wisely and also
on the things it is and spent time as
well because we all know the rages of
inflation
um the
residents definitely acknowledge the
importance of the investment in straford
hospital because all residents many
residents even from my part of the
district come over to stord for for it
so we we do value we realize that is
important but what some residents still
think that s investment seems to be stru
with Town Centric so one of the things
we would like potentially to see is a
map of recent allocations over the last
few years where that's happening again
and we've got the evidence we can dispel
Miss misinformation that I seem to be
encountering in many guyses today so um
not here necessarily but um I think it's
important that misinformation is is is
challenged we'd also like to see whether
there's any barriers of Entry to
applying for seal applications so we
might have really switched on
communities or towns and parishes that
able to to navigate the process properly
and get their bids in and accepted
whereas other communities might have
similar projects of similar
Merit having trouble engaging so again
that might not be the case but do we
know that 100% so again we would like to
see that as is as part of the process um
and again it's touch on that point that
Council Rock and I raised about
communication particularly in rural
areas and again communication
consultation
and making sure they they are able to
respond so I think it's a wider process
as well um and the only other thing
about it is that um members of osc would
be more than willing to assist or peer
review or sense check any proposals come
forward from Council cach and Mr kford
um to make sure that they are open and
transparent and subject to the
sufficient scrutiny so that offer is a
genuine offer um and you might even have
to have me do it how what I was say um
I'm I'm sure count is noding that's
that's always a good sign so I think
that was a really good debate and uh we
welcome the changes um we acknowledges
um things will probably need to change
and uh and we want to make the process
help make the process is open and
transparent and ex accessible as
possible so thank you for that um
councelor Crump you made a very good
point about uh the need for supports for
communities um and
organizations uh for Grants and um being
able to find matched fundings I I I have
experience of this with my own community
and being able to um The Importance of
Being able to find people who are able
to put these bids together uh and and um
some organizations some communities have
that and some don't uh and it's
something that I think feel um we can
you know help communities with um if we
can you know within give by giving them
the the advice it's it's extremely
important so take that I take that on
board um we now have the um the the
recommendations uh before us uh that uh
have we had that moved councelor cter
you've moved it uh did I get a second I
can't remember whether I did get a
second counselor growup okay are you
happy with to move that those
recommendations with the addition that
um to the recommendations that are on
the page which is that we option D table
four the two items will be added to the
recommendations um to fund two
organizations uh extra organizations one
in fin Compton and one in lington okay
are you happy to accept those that yes
yeah okay all right happy to with that
agreed thank
you moving on
then uh and uh and welcoming councelor G
back in who who had to leave and
councelor Co also had to leave because
they were had had um
um items that um that were on there that
were considered in for their that they'
have been involved with the next item is
the member development working group
forward plan page 361
362 uh and this comes under councelor
G um apologies should have been a report
and included in the pack and obviously
you can see the size of the pack it was
inadvertently missed there's a t there's
a table yeah um uh move the
recommendation that the work program as
presented in the table that you've got
in front of you be
approved and are you moving that yes and
Council call seconding it thank you very
much indeed are you all happy to accept
that thank
you um next one is issues arising from
overview and scrutiny committee uh
councelor Crump those items that we
perhaps have not discussed so far during
this meeting obviously the main I think
one of the main points was the cell and
I think we've we've expressed those
quite well and acknowledged that the
points prer and reasonable uh we talked
about we had the Housing Association
task and finish group it's chairs by
councelor Wally hoggins uh CIB actually
came in as well and they were really
helpful as well well uh and the group
will have two more meetings in January
and February uh before a final report
going to osc before Easter um certainly
been a worthwhile exercise um hard work
and well thanks the officers
particularly canel Homer sorry canel
Homer I insult you that um for for all
the help and support and obviously Mr
Allon who's not here but he's he's been
a great help he's been uh been like
hering cats for him um trying to get
everybody there so um but no it's it's
it's been really really good um will
there will be an task and finish group
from osc um that will have several
members on it several volunteers we
actually had that many volunteers it was
is unbelievable um I think councelor
cursus was shot by the number of
volunteers um and not all of whom will
be part of osc we thought that
it could be possible to invite members
with particular expertise to come along
and I think councelor Harvey was was
mentioned and I believe
the councilor Ro would be organizing
somebody from the liberal Democrat group
who was not on osc to come as well but
we haven't heard anything that I think
was that our understanding councelor
Curtis was
that yeah I like all these agreements
you Mrs Bank could be writing councelor
s so agreed with counselor Crump and
cancer Junior deg so could be that many
much agreement it be seriously I think
you I think that's it's F and wise to do
that climate change panel um minutes are
coming on later um there are things that
we're going to be looking up
particularly on transport and and the
offices and Mr Perks um agreed that uh
we could have an overview of the current
position so we could establish some key
lines of inquiry uh how to progress this
because there's still some uncertainty
and I think that we need some more uh
more clarity around
that um regarding the actual minutes
itself from the climate exchange panel
there's many decent action points coming
out of them but we would welcome a time
scale around those to be associated with
them and perhaps some more Precision
Precision around the action
points um talk about updating as much as
possible the climate change pages on the
website it's still ongoing and then we
find discussed um an organization called
climate energy UK who were given us
scorecards on on various council's
performances uh in regarding or wide
manner of the things um there were some
queries anomalies that we were concerned
about uh
regarding the 123 plus refu and
recycling system that we felt because it
was going well because we were one of
the top
10 uh authorities in terms of recycling
and that the score from UK at climate
energy sorry climate emergency UK should
have reflected that we didn't think that
reflected sufficiently well on the
council so we will and we've got the new
climate change project manager I've got
the person's title I couldn't think of
the person's title earlier I've got it
any writers I remember that and we will
be tasking that uh officer to ensure
that we respond robustly but fairly to
ensure these anomalies are not coming
out
because we all know that the amount of
great work that Judy Lewis and Craig
Bourne and the rest of the team have
done on the one two3 uh plus system and
I don't think that was really accurately
ref reflected so I felt strongly we
should Challenge and stand up and make
sure that if we're going to be published
um they publish the right figures or
acknowledge the amount of good work that
we've been doing and Julie I'll have the
five P later for for S so thank you for
that I think that's really important we
had all and Q that the Housing
Association as well and councel R L on
that um we gave Council Curtis a bit of
a hard time regarding the resources and
again Mr borrow agreeing with with
things I were saying that was right so I
am getting worried about this um so
really long meeting
um and the any other thing that came out
was as part of the performance report um
one of the things we've had issue is R
your previously is the communication
strategy we K Rock and I just talked
about it in the meeting as well so it
would be good to see when the um
communication strategy comes out is
ready we would like to consider that as
well um and I think that was about it we
had a long meeting went on until about
20 passord and so um it was a it was a
good meeting but uh some of the members
started to flag towards the end of the
meeting but left yeah but fortunately
the chair kept them on on track with
these wonderful puns and Christmas jokes
so they all stayed away towards the end
otherwise they would have uh had the
rough of my tongue so it it was a really
good meeting so and thank you k ctis for
attending and uh responding effectively
so thank
you thank you very much indeed uh it's
one of the things that I've also picked
up with the um um the climate change
officer is about making sure that um we
are putting things onto the onto the
website you know making making you know
the progress that has been made at The
District Council clear on the website uh
it's one of the things that we we need
to go forward next item is uh cabinet
committees there are none uh no papers
on that um so we move on to part e on
block items uh and for the items in this
section the report and recommendations
will be approved on block unless a
request is made to the leader at the
start of the meeting for the item to be
discussed I've had no request for the
any of the items to be discussed so it's
um we move the enblock items um that uh
the the cabinet work program the climate
change panel um member development
working group cash management working
group straford upon aan Market Forum um
are we happy to move those on block um I
will move them I councelor Cole second
it all
agreed thank you very much uh and the
final pit is uh Part F other matters
urgent business so consider any urgent
business uh we've had nothing approved
nothing uh no request made to us about
urgent business uh so on that notice I
end the meeting thank
you